you're watching some type of hot air
balloon show and you're curious about
how how quickly one hotter balloon in
particular is rising and you have some
information at your disposal you know
the spot on the ground that is directly
below the hot air balloon let's say it
took off from that point it's just been
going straight up ever since and you
know you've measured it out that you're
500 meters away from there so you know
that you are
meters away from that and you're also
able to measure the angle between the
horizontal and the hot air balloon you
could do that with i don't know i'm not
exactly a surveyor but i guess a
viewfinder or something like that so
you're able to and i'm not sure if
that's the right tool but there are
tools that you can measure the angles
between the horizontal and
and something that's not on the
horizontal so you know that this angle
right over here is pi
over 4 radians or 45 degrees we're going
to keep it pi over 4 because when you
take derivatives of trig functions you
assume that you're dealing with radians
so right over here this is pi over 4
radians and you also are able to measure
which the rate at which this angle is
changing so this is changing
changing
changing at
0.2
radians
radians per minute
now my question to you or the question
that you're trying to figure out as you
watch this hot air balloon is how fast
is it rising right now how fast is it
rising just as the angle between the
horizontal and kind of the the line
between you and the hot air balloon is
pi over four radians and the that angle
is changing at 0.2 radians per minute
so let's think about what we know and
what we're trying to figure out so we
know a couple of things we know that
theta is equal to
pi over 4 if we call theta the angle the
angle right over here so this is
theta we also know the rate at which
theta is changing we know d theta let me
do this in yellow we know d theta dt
is equal to 0.2
radians per minute now what are we
trying to figure out well we're trying
to figure out the rate at which the
height of the balloon is changing
so if you call this distance right over
here this distance right over here h
what we want to figure out is d h
d
dt that's what we don't know
so what we'd want to come up with is a
relationship between dh dt d theta dt
and maybe theta if we need it or another
way to think about it if we can come up
with a relationship between h
and theta then we could take the
derivative with respect to t and we'll
probably get a relationship between all
of this stuff
so what's the relationship between theta
and h
well it's a little bit of trigonometry
we know we we're trying to figure out h
we already know what this length is
right over here we know opposite over
adjacent that's the definition of
tangent so let's write that down so we
know that the tangent
the tangent of theta
tangent of theta is equal to the
opposite side the opposite side
is equal to h
over the adjacent side which we know is
going to be a fixed 500
is going to be a fixed 500. so there you
have a relationship between theta and h
and then to figure out to figure out a
relationship between theta d theta and d
h
or d theta dt the rate at which theta
changes with respect to t and the rate
at which h changes changes with respect
to t we just have to take the derivative
of this of both sides of this with
respect to t implicitly so let's do that
and actually let me move over this h
over 500 a little bit
so let me move it over a little bit so i
have space to show the derivative
operator
so let's write it like that and now
let's take the derivative with respect
to t
so d
dt we take the derivative with respect
to t on the left we're going to take the
derivative with respect to t
on the right
so what's the derivative with respect to
t of tangent of theta
well we're just going to apply the chain
rule here
it's going to be first the derivative of
the tangent of theta with respect to
theta which is just secant squared of
theta
times the derivative of theta with
respect to t times d theta dt once again
this is just d the derivative of the the
c sorry the derivative of the tangent
the tangent
of something
with respect to that something
times the derivative of the something
with respect to t derivative of tangent
theta with respect to theta times the
derivative of theta with respect to t
gives us the derivative of tangent of
theta with respect to t which is what we
want when we take the dirt when we use
this type of a derivative upper we're
taking the derivative with respect to t
not just the derivative with respect to
theta fair enough so this is the left
hand side and then the right hand side
becomes
well it's just going to be
1 over 500 dhdt
so 1 over 500
dh dt we're literally saying it's just 1
over 500 times the derivative of h with
respect to t
but now we have our relationship we have
the relationship that we actually care
about we have a relationship between the
rate at which the height is changing
with respect to time and the rate at
which the angle is changing with respect
to time and our angle at any moment so
we can just take these values up here
throw it in here and then solve for the
unknown so let's do that let's do that
right over here so we get secant squared
of theta
so we get secant
squared right now our theta is pi over
four
secant squared of pi over four let me
write those colors in to show you that
i'm putting these values in
secant squared of pi over 4
secant times d theta dt well that is
just 0.2
so times
0.2
and then this is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to
1 over 500 and we want to make sure
since this is in radians per minute
we're going to get we're going to get
meters per and this is this is meters
right over here we're going to get
meters per minute right over here we
just want to make sure all of our we
know what our units are doing i haven't
written the units here for to save some
space but we get 1 over 500 times dh
dt
so if we want to solve for dh dt you can
multiply both sides by 500 and you get
the rate at which our height is changing
is equal to 500
times let's see secant squared of pi
over 4 that is 1 over
cosine squared of pi over 4
cosine of pi over 4. let me write this
over here cosine
of pi
over 4 is square root of 2
over 2
cosine squared of pi over 4 is going to
be equal to
over
2 over 4 which is equal to one-half and
so secant squared
of pi over 4 is just 1 over that is
equal to 2. so this is going to be equal
to let me
rewrite this instead of so the secant
squared of pi over 4 let me erase this
right over here
secant squared of pi over 4 all of this
business right over here simplifies to 2
so times 2 times 0.2 times 0.2
so what is this going to be this is
going to be 500 times 0.4
so this is equal to
times let me write a dot instead times
0.4
which is equal to
let me make sure i get this right this
would be with two zeros only one behind
the decimal yep there you go it would be
200. so the rate at which our height is
changing with respect to time right at
that moment is 200 meters
meters
per
200 meters per minute dhdt
is equal to 200
meters
per minute